alright let's do a show okay you hear
that that's that's the show starting
feels good right feels kind of pro right
okay thank you this is Hollywood
anonymous i am brian are wimping I'm
John Huck across from us is mr. court
mccowan yes I got a comedian actor I
mean you might do more things than that
golfer just came the golf course here
avid golfer a golf dressed lover yeah
yeah I was going to say when you walked
in i'm like man it looks like you just
played golf and I'm like I bet he just
played just played golf right right over
here right by you and the rose bowl Oh
at brookside oh nice yeah are you a
big-time golfer I'm yes I do I play I
play two three times a week oh wow yeah
that's nice but that's I mean it you
know it's like kind of everybody has
their thing you know like people write
bikes or they go to the gym or whatever
you know I mean I play golf I walk I
carry my bag I'm not like it you know
Mike like yeah tulip and you know get in
a cart all the time no you do it for
part of why you do it as the exercise
yeah absolutely absolutely I mean I've
caddied on the PGA Tour on the Champions
Tour this year so I mean it's um it's my
it's like I grew up doing it it's what I
love to do who did who have you caddied
for i caddied for a guy named yes /
Parnevik who's a Swedish Swedish golfer
cool yeah 3 times 3 time Ryder Cup er
one like nine ten times on tour Wow his
uh his nanny Mary tiger woods and that's
it isn't his nanny as this was the one
that yeah golf club through is
absolutely oh um his nanny was uh ylian
oh wow she's a small world John yes
super small world that I'm nowhere near
have a more important question what's it
like to have that kind of time on your
hands to tell ya like corn attorney well
what it is is Yuri Shogun you have
children time your children you have
wife you have those things that I have
no no idea what those things are about
I've heard about those things and for
everything I've heard a horror movie
yeah everything I've heard I'm doing
just fine playing golf two three times a
week I got it okay most people don't
well I got a lucky yeah you do I don't
have any kids and I just don't have any
money so i can't i can't play golf three
times a week and it's not that expensive
it's a lot cheaper than kids well really
it's a watch at the time buying
okay turning it down as cheap ill-fated
right you have to be okay with getting
up early sometimes yep i get up at five
fifteen yeah i can get up early that's
not a big deal and then you just gotta
have a couple hours on your head of time
on your hand where you're not going to
panic because you just you just got to
take your time we go golf and that's the
beauty of golf and it's like you know I
mean we think about it i get up at five
fifteen i drive over here i'm done at
eleven-fifteen so what but at the time
most comedians are waking up yeah I'm
done I'm done playing now I've been up
for a few hours I've had sex ER sighs I
feel love good you know it's like
nothing really happens in this [ __ ]
of a town before noon no that's why to
bed earlier huh do you have to go to bed
early i know days are you know i was
there i was up till almost one last
night that's crazy i started this thing
called meditation i started this Vedic
meditation like eight years ago and I'm
fine with three four hours sleep at
night well I'm behind what this is so
what is this I meditate half an hour in
the morning in half an hour in the
afternoon that's what shuts the body
down so I sit down it treats it like
rest like about a three-hour nap so yeah
so I get that right when I wake up I do
this meditation and even if you're a
little tired it gives you this like tons
of energy that just takes you takes you
into the morning and then around three
four o'clock i do it again and it just
in it and it's just it's better than a
nap is a really half hour huh jungle
normally just drinks and then falls yeah
no no but I mean you know that in the
afternoon I've dealt sure I've done that
in the afternoon have done that in the
morning but but I also started doing I
read a book called eight minute
meditation that a friend of mine is
coworker turned me on to so I read that
and then was doing that and like the
most I've ever meditated for i think is
quite 20 minutes at a time and that was
if that was like two long almost we'll
see what's weird is is like this guy i
learned from i learned from this guy and
he he's like this neuropsychologist you
know in addition to being a meditation
guy and he they did these studies where
they found that when you're like your
brain is that your brain is in a muscle
your brain is neurons so their fights
its firing all the time so every time
you move your hand move your arm
anything even in even in sleep you have
REM sleep you have all those different
things for your brain is actually not
shut down your brain only shuts down for
few hours a night and that's when you
get the deep sleep in the deep rest
right so when you do Vedic meditation as
you as you get further and further along
you actually shut your brain down and
your brain actually goes completely at
rest and it releases stress and it does
all these other things and it actually
your body rests more during meditation
than it does during a nap so you you
know a 30 minute meditation is equal to
or better than a three three and a half
hour nap wow that's the thing I don't
take Madison science podcast right side
yeah I just want to know how does one go
about shutting up shutting off the world
in order to begin to meditate which is
why I've ever done it cuz I cannot shut
my brand-new do what's called a mantra
and they have these things called
mantras and what it is is let's say it's
shreem you know some it's an Indian word
dot not feather and it's an Indian word
and what it is is it doesn't have any
meaning and they call it mantras like a
mind vehicle and so what you do is you
you close your eyes you sit down and you
don't sit in the cross legged position
in the middle of the room you sit with
your back supported users are very
comfortable and you start you close your
eyes and you just very effortlessly try
to repeat that mantra over and over in
your head and after a period of time I
mean thoughts will come in thoughts
always come in if you gotta close the
door and say no thank you no but what
you do is the exactly the opposite is
you let the thoughts come in and then
you just let them complete themselves
and you go back to your mantra the best
way it was described me was it's like
going to a party with your best friend
your best friend your mantra you're not
going to ignore everybody else at the
party but you really want to spend time
with your friend so what you'll do is
you'll let the other people have their
conversations and then you just go back
to the mantra and eventually what
happens is you're so relaxed and your
your your mind is calm down so much you
forget to do your mantra and nothing
comes in and your mind it's just this I
can't even describe how great it feels
but you're conscious and aware of it and
it lasts for the longer you do it the
quicker you get there in the longer at
last okay how did you get yourself out
of it or do you just you literally are
your conscious so you just said I've
done yeah I know I kind of after you've
done I've done it for so long now that I
no when half an hour's up I literally
can like look down at my watch or look
down to the thing go out Slyke been 29
minutes or it's been 31 minutes almost
to the exact moment every single time
now or you can set a timer right i mean
yeah that's what you do at first today
ever one of the egg once and i will they
actually they actually tell you they
actually tell you not to do that and
begin over later on it's fine to do it
because they want you to get used to
that time frame okay there you go were
you always this kind of guy like a
meditation line oh my gah hellah how do
I look at the guy were you were you from
originally oklahoma oklahoma oh no i was
not that kind of guy was the kind of guy
that would do to bong hits before I walk
my dog yeah you know that was the kind
of guy was now you're an Oklahoma kid
how long do you live in Oklahoma for he
bailed I was there until I was um I
moved here when I was 20 20 okay so you
were the you up good portion of your
life was an Oklahoma yeah and what was
that like growing up a lot of people
have perceptions of Oklahoma yeah
they're probably pretty close what's
your perception of Oklahoma I think a
lot of people think they're a tad bit of
hickish and a little bit of racist and a
little bit of cowboy I love their guns
yeah i'm gonna say not is hickish much
more racist they do love their guns and
it's not really hickish as much as I
mean everywhere has their hickish places
you know even yeah yeah yeah i mean but
i don't think of it is that hickish as
much as it was you know it's like it's
just like 15 years earlier yeah yeah
just 15 years earlier except now with
the internet you know when I was growing
up it was you know it was earlier but
now that there's the internet and
everything I don't think there's any
place that's really left in the dark
anymore no unless you do it by choice
yeah but I don't think there really is i
think everybody there's you know there's
j.crew starbucks there's you know all
this [ __ ] stores that are in every place
now yeah and I don't think that there
they are really they're kind of in the
dark but they do are there still in
denial I mean they're they're definitely
a fox news that's a fox news state yeah
you know I mean they hire a black
senator an ex-football player of course
now you can't just be a black center
be a black guy you had to a place holder
right you have played at Oklahoma
University I could get cornhuskers
nebraska yeah yeah show subside I'm I
just became a Midwestern [ __ ] and I'm
from the Midwest um but there but it's
not that it's not that bad and I will
say the nicest people in the world they
really really are I mean I'm white so it
makes it easier but I'm not they really
are nice nice nice people a little you
know I have like one cousin that's like
very like kind of hickish or kind of
like set back and he just bugs the [ __ ]
out of me John and I were talking about
the beautiful sorry John's vanilla no
I'm from Wisconsin and the week that's
the problem i think from the Midwest we
come from the nicest people you're ever
going to meet definitely the nice people
are going to meet and then they will
just spew some sort of ignorant racist
stuff or just something so stupid you're
like seriously you do know what what
what yeah what year it is where we're at
where where you live in society it's
then Milwaukee is very segregated and it
isn't it the most created city in
America sickens me when I go back
because I just I'm kids okay it's our
John does it more than you I head but
the [ __ ] out yeah it bums me out because
I want to be able to go back to where I
grew up and be excited about going back
and then sometimes I go back and I'm
just shaking my head the whole time I'm
they're going come on guys catch up it's
weird man like I have a cousin that
every time I go home for Christmas or
the holidays it's like you know he
always he always says the same [ __ ] so
hows it out there in Hollywood you know
like like I'm running around with like
you're like good stuff yeah yeah it's
just like everybody were all the movie
stars we all eat lunch together and down
everybody and it's like you know I
haven't done a film in like 10 years
once you back the [ __ ] off you know and
he's a DJ and I used that in air quotes
because like she's lazy theater yeah he
uses I don't think he's as a computer I
think he uses like cassettes has like a
dual cassette that Columbia House what
bank robbery i didn't know that even
still exist as me warts cousin didn't
pay his [ __ ] name and tapes for a
penny yeah no idea that was even still
available we go now we know who is still
buying them yeah I mean this guy like he
was like you know he plays weddings and
you know and he's like he really gets
jiggy I don't know you know yeah and I
just I feel there's a legend in his own
mind so when did you decide that
Oklahoma was not we're going to hang
that for the rest of your life well I
have one of those great like Hollywood
stories like that like the real like
crazy Hollywood thing like I actually
came out here I came out here for a
vacation I had a buddy who was it was a
stand-in on a TV show but had been
telling me that he was you know in he
was living in Hollywood and you know he
came back I was going to school and
stillwater at Oklahoma State and he kept
he's like you know tell us all these
stories and of course this is like late
night this is now you understand this is
1981 no no 1984 1984 and this is like
you know just blow everywhere yeah and
you know you're up till six in the
morning and it's like yeah you know
you're starting businesses together yeah
you're gonna save the world you're just
doing it all you know you're doing
everything every day you're like what
the [ __ ] yeah everybody is your best
friend you know everybody's the best
buddies and I was with this guy you know
it and I knew him a little bit I didn't
know him really well but he was like you
know listen if you ever want to come out
to LA man you can stay with me man
you'll have a great time he got the
invite viale which is saying that he
probably invited a lot of people and
then maybe you were the one that showed
up and he was like holy [ __ ] well know
what I called him and I said listen
Larry I appreciate that you know I'm
thinking about like taking a little
vacay and and at the time I was um I was
a mess man i mean i was i was doing a
lot of drugs and i was on probation at
school it wasn't going well you know was
not going well it was time to go yeah
but I was but I was studying like I had
done theatre when I was younger I was in
radio television i was i was a disc
jockey at the college station you know i
was i was you know kind of working at
all these different things in that kind
of feel but there's really no market in
oklahoma for this honor but at the time
i was so you know I was 20 years old I
didn't know what I wanted to do yet and
i ended up I called Larry and so I'm
gonna come out for I'm going to come out
for 10 days man I need to get I need to
get the [ __ ] out of here and he's like
yeah man come on out come on out and so
I literally got on America West and this
is back when you know way before TSA
and you literally would write a check on
the plane like you would sit down
playing you would go oh yeah they come
by with a little thing like a train
conductor almost later like Peter like
yeah yours you know cuz it was all the
same pry it was like a hundred dollars i
think it was hundred dollars for one-way
ticket yet from Tulsa to to LA and I
came out it was the Summer Olympics the
84 summer olympics so I was coming out
you can get out here yeah routed in [ __ ]
because a lot of people from Tulsa
coming to the flight was not under
control it's like kicking back with a
whole row to yourself with your uncle
holding chickens and some of the Rose
yeah a lot of that yeah a lot of cowboy
hats um but and then I what I did was is
I you know I was going out to see Larry
so I had a you know I had a butt load of
[ __ ] on me so I am partying my balls off
all the way in America West was free
drinks so I party like a great drinks
coke in the bathroom like yeah like
answers a rock star you know on this
plane going out there and you could
smoke back then on planes do I guess so
we're all standing in the back we all
the glory days people we're all stand in
the back of the plane smoking cigarettes
doing lines drinking you know it's just
insane you know Boogie Nights flies and
it's only like three hours and I'm
shit-faced man and I get off the plane
there's Larry's like yeah you know we
[ __ ] we go back he lived on Laurel
Avenue right above the laughs act oh
nice and so we go back to his place we
stay up to a one or whatever and he goes
hey listen man I can't I got to go to
sleep i'm working tomorrow do you want
to work do you want to work as an extra
tomorrow look literally that quick you
view better got off the plane you
partied till one and he goes hey I gotta
go to bed you want to work tomorrow as a
background guy yeah do you wanna work as
an extra nice vacation just so I'm clear
this is not moving to town yeah no no no
this was on vacation but I was like he I
go dude man I mean I'm kind of tight
right now I mean like I'm messed up
because we had to get up at six in the
morning we had to leave at six in the
morning and he was working all the way
out in woodland hills and I was like oh
[ __ ] man I go he goes it pays a hundred
bucks I'm like oh [ __ ] I'll do it I'll
wait yeah I mean that was like a
thousand dollars at that time and and so
I was like yeah man no problem no
problem and now you understand this is
july in woodland hills so
it's about a hundred and forty-two
degrees outside and I didn't know I
didn't know anything about the movie
business I didn't know anything about it
so my thoughts were he's like you're
gonna be in this party scene so you
gotta wear con you get a dress like you
know kind of like like you're in a party
this is you know this is the 80s so it's
you know you can imagine that there
should i colors and you know I have
feathered hair my hair was down like all
the way past my shoulders you know
everybody was an eagle painting yes
everyone was in a go painting and and so
we know not even Nagel yet I don't
wasn't Nagel yeah maybe it was but it
was just bad man it was just not not
good looking and and so I went to work
with him the next day and I had no idea
what I was in for and when you're an
extra you are literally treated like a
piece of dirt so they have us outside
and we're shooting at this junior high
school where they did Karate Kid and
we're doing this TV show it's this TV
show called dreams and it was John
Stamos Jami Gertz Ron kara BOTS all
these different it was kind of I love
jami gertz I the fact that you're
remembering all this well I just it's
kind of one of those things where it's
your first time yeah so you know you
know and I and I in so to make the long
story longer so I get in there we and
I'm sitting outside it's like seven
seven in the morning we're there and I'm
like I don't my just is everything I can
do not to throw up I'm actually did a
couple bumps on the way to the last I
love it that's because I that's gonna
even you out it's gonna even me out and
I was just like I was not feeling good I
didn't bring the extra gear I needed the
egg to be and share the book the guitar
you know every like you know water yes
things that they don't really provide
for you yeah and and I was like Jesus
Christ man i'm sitting out there and i
was like [ __ ] well luckily about nine
o'clock we've been up there about two
hours and I was kind of like I needed
that two hours so I didn't puke but then
it started getting hot and I was like oh
[ __ ] man that's gonna hot now I'm
starting to really wig out I'm starting
to sweat and then they've got a good
sweat everybody that guy looks wet is
not it's like the gnarliest sweat you
can have Scotch coming out oh yeah just
bleeding booze
Scott early for that during the time
you're probably just like every other
extra their dish smelling weather is
weighing ya thank ya you weren't
sticking out but also just for anybody
listening like there was no cellphones
no like you were when you say you were
there with nothing that means like
you're basically David putty from
Seinfeld staring at the back of a seat
you're like a hundred percent percent
and I think and and I didn't know
anybody there no yeah you know and the
fact that I and this is Union so the
fact that i'm actually at this thing one
of their friends didn't get a job so
they [ __ ] hate me already you know
and and I'm like okay you know I don't
know what to [ __ ] tell you know that
so but my buddy Larry's inside in the
air conditioning and I'm like you
[ __ ] in tulare and so finally we
get called in for the party scene and
we're in this party scene it's fun you
know I'm like oh this is kind of cool
and we're in you know they had one of
those big yellow hoses that had the air
conditioning yeah pulled off the whole
[ __ ] room yeah and I'm and I'm just
like standing in front of that thing and
now I gotta have it now I gotta have the
air conditioning because I you know the
thought of going back outside is not
good because we shoot the scene I'm like
in front of the camera it's like I mean
I was in the whole thing and cuz larry
was like hooking me up you know like his
visitor for me it was Larry's part in it
what larry was just stand-in oh he was
Stanford he were stand-in for there was
a guy named Cain Devore who was on there
okay sue is a red another kind of like
light-skinned Larry had read Harry look
a lot like you without a beard that's
too bad Larry I'm so sorry and and so
what ended up happening was is is they
break in everybody no they go okay
that's we're done with a sound outside
background out and I just [ __ ] win
over and I snuck over by that yellow
snake and I just sat in a director's
chair just right in front I look like
that maxell tape commercial hear the
words just blow back and I had really
long hair back then too so I'll in the
wind baby so that so a few minutes goes
by and I'm just sitting around like so
happy and this guy comes to taps on my
sure he goes hey John we need you in the
scene and I was like Joan and I go no
I'm not John he goes oh he goes oh
alright well who are you and I go on
court he goes what do you what are you
doing here and I said I'm with my friend
Larry because well you know kept going
he goes we're now you got to go outside
and I go
I'm not going outside and he goes well
you can't be in here and then he just
walked away and then I was like [ __ ]
that guy I like I'm not doing that like
I can say it all you want cuz most Xers
are afraid like I didn't give a [ __ ] I
you know that's the that's the advantage
you have is not knowing and not caring
yeah and I didn't carry and so I was
sent down there and a couple people keep
coming up to me going John because they
didn't know cuz I from the back you
couldn't tell me in Stamos apart our
hair was you see are all same Lee favor
John stainless I didn't a guy named God
and so finally the director photography
comes over to me he goes hey listen he
goes you know I could really use a guy
that could be a photo double for John he
goes from the back you guys cannot
you're the exact same size the same
height and you any goes I could really
use a guy like that and I was like do I
get to stay inside he's like yeah you
get this enols or whatever you want and
he goes great I go that's great man I'm
gonna be here for 10 days he goes oh he
goes I need someone for 10 weeks and I
was like I go I go can I let you know
tomorrow and he goes young and he goes I
go but I can do it today right he goes
yeah yeah you can do it today so what
they did is this was a TV show where at
the end of every show they would film a
music video this was the they were in a
band is they were in a band yes I a Glee
remember this show yeah and so what they
would do is at the end everything but
Stamos was it was his first series after
general hospital or I think with general
hospital he was on so he was really
expensive he was really highly paid so
they needed a lot of they want to get
him out of there and they needed someone
to film they could shoot the long shots
and you know they didn't you didn't have
to tell so I went back to the house with
Larry and we talked and I was like you
know what [ __ ] I'm gonna do it so I
went back the next day and I said I
meant man put me in for Tim Lee so I
just and that was it I moved out you
know back home what were you leaving
anything behind at the time not really
right in the lowes I had a shitty old
Chrysler Cordova I left in the front
yard you know it's terrible at mag we
ever go back to get it I did I went no I
went back the card gotten towed okay um
because it's SAT there I went I stayed
for five weeks and then we had a hiatus
and then I came back for a week got all
my [ __ ] came back out and then when I
back my car was gone my brother my
brother lived like two doors down didn't
even look after he's like such a douche
you ever know what happened to that car
my brother said he saw it at an auction
like the car would it make a hundred
bucks I mean it was probably worth i
think i paid 800 for it so it was like I
mean it for you is like good riddance it
was good riddance and i was making like
i was making huge I consensus as a photo
double slash stand-in at the time and
union you were making 109th 140 140 48
hours and then you were making and then
you made from 10 to 12 was like time and
a half you never were working in hours
you're working yeah you're right 12
hours in 10 to 12 was was double yeah
and then after that was what they call
golden which was like ridiculous so i
was making like i was making like
fifteen sixteen hundred dollars a week
which back then I pray C++ health health
insurance plus in all your benefits
everything was taken care of because
your goddamn hair all because it really
boiled down to that dead lock of hair
that was flowing from there the AC unit
and the guy in the guy that was the
second ad on that was such a cool guy
he's the one who brought me in to do
teen wolf right after that he was the
second ad this show got cancelled and it
was it got canceled after 13 epic legit
but but rightly so oh I mean it was him
on the Sun over the more I remember the
shell the more when you say the
musically at the end I remember even as
a kid going oh man [ __ ] that you know
what was weird it's like I got to see
like it was like her the coolest
Hollywood thing because like Bill Bixby
was one of the directors he was like a
regular director Bill dicks yeah Bill
Bixby that's that is David Banner from
The Incredible Hulk yeah it was a big
speed was a director on all the time
John Peters and Peter Guber were the
executive producers barbra streisand's
husband so it was like this really not a
Hollywood power yeah they were huge at
the time and it was this big this big
deal and it was CBS's Big Show and
unfortunately it just didn't it didn't
hit but I mean Lou Rawls was on the show
they had a sound stage set up at this
word you know that where they did Karate
Kid they took over the junior
school they had in the gym was like was
the bar in another room I mean they had
all these these permanent set set up in
the house they had a sound recording
studio set up because they released a
single on every on everyone and I mean I
remember I remember Lou Rawls like was
there and Lou Rawls was huge you know
even though he was huge and we got to go
like hangin like watch Lee Rawls record
and it was kind of like at that time I
mean I was 20 I think I turned 21 when I
was there and it was like I mean Stamos
would take us to the red onion you know
which or whatever was TGI Fridays in the
valley he lived in like preceded and
we'd all go out which is paying girls it
was like it was just like you see if you
just use the term we all went out to TGI
Fridays and girls yeah it was the 80s
lady that was TGI Fridays was different
back then man how they cut you off after
two beers yeah I mean it was like back
then it was like anybody went to TGI
Fridays now to bank girls he said they'd
be like hey bro get out oh no TGI
Fridays and the rent onion had like
night they had like a disc like
nightclubs so it was like a nightclub so
you didn't go there to eat you went
there to hang out in the bar yeah and
party with the girls and I mean there
were hot girls this was like the 80s so
you go there and it was like boom yeah
this is the first six months of your
this is like six months this is before
teen wolf oh yeah okay but this is six
months up that this is you taking a
ten-day vacation and this is what what
during that ten day vacation became a
10-week stay yeah which turned into all
this the turn in all this yeah I'm it
and I we got done they canceled that
show in like December where were you
living did you stay living with your
buddy or did he ask you to kind of get
out I live with my buddy I live with my
buddy for a little bit and then some
people we met some friends of his lived
on hayworth right behind what's now the
coffee bean which back then was like a
bank this is that sunset this is sunset
and Haworth and so he moved into
Hollywood like literally right in
Hollywood get a spot dude I used to
smoke pot with the hookers the hookers
used to hang out at the directors guild
used to be so it was a different place
by the way sheriff I stole away
different it's like Broadway in New York
like it's different this was when
Schwab's drugstore was still still there
is now 9000 sunset Schwab's drugstore
was there the the coconut teaser which
is now hide there's this little bitty
joint little bitty like rib and chicken
joint that was down on Crescent Heights
that was like I mean the whole worth at
9,000 it was one level it was just one
level of like storefronts that wrapped
around in the Schwab's drugstore there
was this there was this and then there
was this coconut teaser read walk in and
they had chicken on the Reno roasting
chicken and you could buy tequila shots
for a quarter when you ordered so they
have this thing that looked like a you
know a rack of like of billiards you
know so all the balls you know when you
get your balls but they had all the shot
glasses in there so you would go up and
when you ordered food they say do you
want you want tequila you couldn't like
take it to the table but you would order
it they'd have limes in a glass there
and you would just have to drink it
there you drink there but we'd go there
order do like five shots and then go sit
down you know and then eat and then it
eventually moved across the street you
know but it was yeah I lived over on
hayworth for a long time I live with
some other people that you had not met
so you were living with other people but
yeah oh yeah I mean I was yet you were
back then it was like roommates but i
think my rent was like 300 guy but you
were if so what was it like for you
coming from oklahoma and just or did you
not care about living with strangers
that was never a big deal you were
already so like literally high in life
both little yeah no I mean I had ryanne
hi um yeah I was high a lot so it didn't
matter were you ever kind of like what's
up with these people were as long as
somebody vouch for somebody you were
that guy's well no you what you would do
is is like for example like one of it
like I worked with I met this one girl
who was she was an extra she worked she
a lot of people were like in this extra
is kind of stand-in we were all actors
actresses trying but see what I did to
is this when I first got here iced I you
know I realized that's what I wanted to
do like I ok I want to be an actor you
know and in an 84 it was like it wasn't
like now it wasn't like everybody was an
actor and so I went like I've enrolled
in the the school this guy John lynn who
was like you know Stanislawski I mean it
was like method it was like crazy
intense thing and you would go in there
with her guys that were working already
that you knew from [ __ ] you know and
you're like in john lim was like the
[ __ ] real deal and you know he's like
his name is in the book for the actor
studio like that kind of guy and so he
was like really cool and you went in I
started started studying at night in his
class and then you started doing all
these different jobs you know I mean you
would you know you saw you meet people
and this one girl I met was she was
actually Cybill Shepherd standing on
moonlighting and she and she was like
the stand in circles what you're saying
yeah I said I was above the extra slum
yeah but that's a little coy moving
[ __ ] hobby was there a bar that was
called stand-ins and that's where you
guys all met and we can start that I can
start that part it was a good bar and
but he was but back then it was union
money so I mean it was like you can make
a decent let could make a very good
living you know I mean you were making
you know you're making 70 you know well
let's I mean I'd say you're probably
making six seven thousand dollars a
month and back then that's I mean that's
double value no that's double that now
and and rents were cheap man I mean I
think are we had a two bedroom apartment
beautiful apartment on hayworth it was a
big apartment and it was two bedroom two
bath and I think we paid six no no no I
don't think we paid that I think we paid
like 550 a month yeah now that the same
apartment is five thousand fifty dollars
a month again the Sunset Strip again
living over there and all that said was
just different back then right it was
different yeah I mean there was nothing
there was not much going on I mean you
had down there you had gazzarri's and
you had the rainbow robberies ya know
the rocks he was big because that's
where Belushi was hanging out on top at
on the rocks you know in all those
places I mean he had died right before I
got in there but that was still kind of
like the this [ __ ] that was where a lot
of stuff was going on there i mean
Hollywood was different I mean it was
really seedy a Hollywood Boulevard was
just all that it was a knife fight I
mean that was just I was just homeless
people you should go there no no you let
her run quick oh yeah we'll all the
nightclubs back then there where
everybody went out at night all those
were downtown so everything in it yeah
everything's of downtown had like an oh
don't be downtown was chin
downtown was were all the clubs were
they were great big clubs and it was and
it was like that but I mean you had you
know you had what was what's the name of
that place on santa monica right there
the pub Barney's Barney's Barney's
Beanery now you got to realize no to
this is 1984 1985 and West Hollywood was
not a city yet but there was boys town
you know I was going on and Barney's
Beanery was this old pub that was like
four straight people that was right in
the heart of boystown and they used to
have a sign above the door sign that
hung above the door and written on all
the matches no [ __ ] allowed a serious
wow so they used to have a big sign that
hung above the door and on every match
book was printed no [ __ ] allowed like
you said there's Hicks everywhere yeah
right in the heart but if you had one of
those matchbooks I gotta be worth
something yeah but hey that's how you
look at it this yeah yeah that's great I
mean it's just such a way that's great
you couldn't do that I mean imagine do
that in west hollywood now no pets
allowed well they earned it i think the
minute it turned into a city they they
put a kibosh on that it was there
survive that it was there for a long
time well I mean you know I mean it was
kind of that was a place I mean it was
where there was like a hundred and fifty
different beers it was it was a really
cool place you know and if you're saying
variety save them from being a-holes yep
a variety well this was this before it
was Barney's right no this is what was
bad Bart has always been burning you
know and it was a it was a little bit
more of a bit more European I mean you
know there was there was a couple of
different places where was the cat &
fiddle pub but the cat & fiddle pub was
on Laurel Canyon underneath the canyon
country store oh wow so that's where the
cat & fiddle pub was so we used to walk
as we're get just trashed and we used to
walk up Laurel Canyon because it was
only what a quarter-mile you walk up
there and we'd go to the cat & fiddle
pub and that was the only place that had
bass ale on tap so you go there and you
play darts you drink to your blind and
then you just walk back down laurel
canyon to the house on hayworth and
that's where you go and I mean there was
coaching horses there's a few of those
places but for the most part you know
everything of the night
I was downtown I was downtown you know
and and you know Santa Monica was
nothing so were you this whole time were
you like you were just loving life
you're like a Hollywood is pretty sweet
this this gigs pretty easy or were you
or were you kind of I'd have a business
mentality to of like what's the next
thing coming for me like how did you
approach living out here because it's
you like you said that's pretty crazy
you show up here a little bit of cocaine
next thing you know you're in the
business which nobody has that you know
exact story well it's kind of weird as I
had like five years I when I first got
here from 1984 to 1989 1990 it really
was good like I didn't really have
nothing nothing really slowed down I
mean everything actually everything got
better and better and better each wall
was bigger and everything will ya
because I started out like when I did
that show dreams I was that was like
great and then that show ended and I was
like oh [ __ ] what next but I had money
saved up because you didn't you know
just made so much money in your I wasn't
very much so you have money saved up and
then you were like the you would you
knew something else was coming and then
you would take little side jobs or you
do something in between so then like we
got a call like to do this do this show
you know this guy that was a second ad
called me and Larry up and he goes hey I
got this gig he goes I need two young
guys that aren't fuck-ups because most
exit back then atmos texts we were all
[ __ ] I mean just two people are fuck-ups
there they really you know you didn't
know what was going on you know and I
once I got that job like I took it real
seriously weird about the first job yeah
well and I always did it whenever I got
on set I was like I tried to learn what
was going on because the stand-in job is
not easy you have to if you don't know
what a stand-in is if your listeners
don't know what it is is basically a you
know group comes in you've directed
stuff so you know but it's like a group
comes in and they do a you know they do
a walk through the scene where they
block it and then the actors aren't
going to stand there while they light it
right take an hour hour and a half so
they leave in the standings basically
walk and do exactly what the ass that
contain second team yeah and so you know
you're when you're a second team it's
like a lot of second team guys they're
just [ __ ] off all day long they don't
care they know they're making good money
you know they hear second team and they
walk up there like well where do you
want me to go and there's because
there's
marks on the floor they don't even know
what the [ __ ] they're doing I was always
paying attention when didn't know what
was happening but you you got yourself
in with the crew yeah the crew likes you
you're good to go and you got a DS and
should bring you back yourself that says
a lot yeah yeah and then that's what
happened is these ad causes calls me and
Larry and he goes hey listen I got this
gig it's going to be like five weeks
work and you know we're gonna need you
guys are going to be in this thing a lot
and I was like okay cool and it was Teen
Wolf and so we got to be on this bath
you needed two guys there was two guys
that were not principal characters they
were on his basketball team on Michael J
Fox esteem he's being Larry I'm in the
whole [ __ ] movie you know I mean I
even IMDb gives me credit for it you
know it is you know I mean it was one of
those things and and that movie I don't
know was it was super popular when it
came out right because it's still well
what happened was lastic Michael J Fox
did that movie oh free and then they
shelved it then they shelved it until
Back to the Future came out and Michael
J Fox to his people try to stop that
movie from coming out because they were
like no no no no no they it was a good
it was it they liked it oh ok ok came
out yeah pretty good yeah but but that
you're right it came out it was done
before back to the future but came out
after yeah yeah that's hilarious cuz
then I was like a Michael J Fox party
train going on at that point he was such
a nice guy though man he was the Atlas
guy ever yeah you see one of those guys
it's his first big movie bought his
first new car cuz back then man you
gotta remember family ties was kind of
Meredith baxter-birney show it wasn't
like the Michael J Fox show he slowly
had Bashar but she did slowly over time
over the seasons so especially after
back to the future and Teen Wolf he
became the huge star that's what that's
what put they put him in front okay but
you're still doing family ties when he
did back oh yeah oh yeah he was doing
everything back then even that's how it
works I mean he's it back to the future
two I think when he was like still doing
family ties he would do that at night
and do the family ties during the day
whatever or however that worked yeah but
I mean he was such a nice guy i mean i
mean i worked on family ties the last
the second to the last episode of their
their series and I remember like he was
such a [ __ ] cool guy I was working on
a TV show on the back lot of universal
about seven eight months after teen wolf
and I'm walking to the commissary Nilis
here this this horn honk and I turn its
michael in his yet this it gotten this
like 280zx was this first car and he
loved it because the radio was on the
mysterious one of the first time the
radio that's awesome and we used to ride
around in this kapar 'king lot outside
the gymnasium we were doing basketball
smoke cigarettes and didn't draw any
would drive and you know it's really
cool so i got this honk on universal I
turn around to Michael and he goes dude
you gotta see he was he was doing these
doing voice voiceover stuff for back to
the future and he took me in and gave me
a little show me it is still just a
little bit of it but he was such a nice
guy and he was like you know and then I
remember I went and did family ties and
he was so cool he's like you know can
you come have dinner with me and his
wife you know because we were going to
you know whatever I think we rehearsed
or shot or something we had rehearsal
and you had dinner then we did their
live taping and I think he was like but
I couldn't do it because I had to do
some blocking stuff but he was in that's
kind of guy he was yeah what was Ollie
what did you did you do in the episode
were you just doing the stand-in thing
no I know this was when I this is at
this time I'd been working so that I
used up my next question so what did you
actually go from just being like a
standard or featured extra into actually
well I think to get acting gigs well
after a teen wolf I started I started
doing this thing called go between
services where I would deliver scripts
and resume it was it was it long story
muscle my service messenger service but
it was before fax machines and email to
everything so I hit every studio every
agents office all the time there's a
package here's my headshot yes exactly I
got almost got fired because I kept
putting my head shot in the casting
director for Cagney and Lacey and this
guy fuad who was like they operate you
know like that the whatever you call
them the dispatch dispatch dispatch your
fuad like because we had CB radios you
know screw outcomes because you [ __ ]
idiot there they are casting for
pregnant woman why cut your [ __ ]
picture in there because I [ __ ] fire
you you piece of [ __ ]
and you were trying me I was trying all
the time and and then I but I put my
head shot him with this lady named
ivette pickoff who was an agent at the
time she was on sunset and she kept one
day she goes she goes where do I know
you from and she kept on I go I don't
know and she goes how about these 50
[ __ ] no I was like oh and she goes
are you in sag and I was like no she
goes when you get in sag you give me a
call I appreciate I get your persistence
so long story short I got into sag I did
was doing this show called George Burns
comedy week and it was with George Burns
George Burns was like he would come in
and do a green screen and do the intro
for all of it but would you actually
around George Burns and stop you first
ladies I see you met George burger
lutely holy [ __ ] dude I mean it were you
holy [ __ ] at the time or were you kind
of like whatever do you realize that you
got understand okay this was the this
was maybe the greatest show to ever work
on because I was standing at the time
and it was called George Burns comedy
week it was produced by Steve Martin and
Carl Gottlieb cargo libro jaws also
called they so what every week was a
different cast with a different director
in a different setting it was like you
remember amazing stories yeah this was
the comedy version of Amazing Stories so
they called it George Burns comedy week
because every week would be like one
week would be the story about a
millionaire who's going to give away a
million dollars to whoever can make him
laugh you know because he's never
laughed it's all the next one is about
you know uh spy thing you know whatever
the next one's about a small town you
know in the middle of nowhere that has
you know that has a gold mine that
nobody you know it's just it's all
comedy but I mean I got to work with on
this thing this is like the list is just
enormous like telly savalas Elliott
Gould come on Don Rickles get out of
here Don Knotts come on Fannie Flagg
Paul Reiser when he was young Jack
guilford I mean just like God I mean the
list that's Harvey Korman Carrie Fisher
Wow Steve Martin directed his first
episode and we had directors like John
Landis and Steve Martin directed his
first show on that
Phil and then I got lucky in that I
worked really really hard on this like I
really was i said you never just [ __ ]
off more like I'm Hollywood this is
awesome no never you always like so you
actually always appreciated what I
really appreciate it what I had and I
was like and I in the what I found
through going to acting classes and
stuff because now I was like really into
it and I was studying hard and I was
getting better and what I was learning
was is that you could do all these
things you were doing in class we're all
fine but that didn't teach you how to
stand up and sit down in a chair on
right because once you're on camera it's
like shits different and I was like now
I [ __ ] know [ __ ] I know I
know what to do like you like I'll never
be afraid of being in front of a camera
now but I do we see people i get jobs
and it's like they look like idiots in
front of the camera cuz the director
I'll be god no no you can't do that yeah
I know you gotta move here like like to
walk up and you know say your line while
you're hitting your mark without having
to look down at your feet and you know
how to do all these things so I was
learning all this and I but I was always
there and then one day they just go
because it you couldn't get into sag
unless you got a line you had to get a
little oh there's a Taft are left i SAT
taft-hartley so you couldn't get it you
couldn't get into the show couldn't get
into sag unless you had a line in sag
show be couldn't get a line in sac show
unless you had a sag card it was like
yeah catch-22 catch-22 so one day I went
to work and they go sorry but you're not
you're not a standing today I'm like oh
[ __ ] like who backstabbed me a new [ __ ]
man yeah how'd I get fired and they took
me outside they had a trailer at
universal backlot the reverse they beat
you up in a trailer back there and they
[ __ ] gave me a line in the show like
the Emmis phil alden robinson because
they like you again I think I always say
to people if you want to work in this
town you have to be like you cannot be
an [ __ ] people work with until until
your until you're well known then you
can be a complete ass [ __ ] and just
fail upwardly yes yes last year which
insurance design your fair share of yeah
it's like it's different and and I mean
it was so nice because I I did a scene
with Martin Mull yeah and and it was
like it was great thing and they were
really cool and it was like and I
remember like Phil Robinson who wrote
field of dreams and directed he was the
director and they were all like so nice
to give me this thing
and then I went back like that like the
next week and I go here if I go I'm in
sag and she goes okay and she started
sending me up on stuff and then the
first thing i got was can't buy me love
and then i got this great you know I got
this movie that was nothing at the time
you know was nothing no it was called
boy rents girl Patrick Dempsey was not
really known yeah you know but he was
this I mean he was what sold that movie
right like that's what people know well
before I remember correctly that that
whole genre just took off so it grabs
some of these types of movies that maybe
had not planned on being as big a hits
become hits because it was a genre of
this style of movie those being made at
that time correct well it was a little
bit and then we got we really like I
said we really got lucky because at this
time we were a small budget film I think
it was like a three million dollar movie
it was tiny you know which is pretty
small and it was done by this company
called Apollo pictures was this guy
who's not even with the same where I
think his name is Jerry Henshaw and he
basically did anything close to porn at
the you know I mean he was just not a
reputable right reputable guy but he was
though um you know he was just shady and
we did the small movie and I mean
literally I mean Dennis Dugan was in it
I mean he was like a huge director now
but Dennis Dugan played like Patrick
Dempsey's father there was like nobody
you really knew like nobody really known
and Patrick Dempsey all he done for the
most part was he starred in a TV series
called fast times at ridgemont high and
that couldn't have done well it and
oddly enough it didn't in it and it
didn't do well I got to work on the show
but it was but it but the only person
that was in it was ray walston mr. hand
was in it horse and then the the science
teacher although the guy was in better
off dead too yeah and and he was in it
and but it was still Amy Heckerling who
wrote and did fast times did the
director oh wow yeah and her husband
Neil um what's Neil it doesn't matter
you have an insane memory by the way
yeah um but it was so it was like fun
but anyway so we did this movie and then
after we did this movie I remember we
got called everyone we're gonna have a
party and they called something we're
gonna have this big party come over the
house we got a big surprise for you guys
went to this big house for this party in
mark Berg who was the director who is
the co-producer on the show who now is
famous for like representing Charlie's
charlie sheen's manager okay he's done
all the saw movies and never given me a
job go [ __ ] yourself yeah you like I
think he owns a [ __ ] hockey team now
you such a prick and now now you're a
nice guy mark I love you please please i
need something um but anyway they all
went over there and they and they had
this guy there and this guy comes over
and i remember these names just because
at the time it was this guy names guys
name was chris narvis and he worked for
touchstone which was disney's an arm of
disney version their PG version of
movies and and they go we just bought
your movie so this was the first movie
the touchstone ever bought that they
didn't make themselves and they go
you're all going back to Arizona we're
going to reshoot some of this stuff and
we're gonna release this and we're gonna
call it can't buy me love and we got
this and we did this and we're all like
yeah we're gonna release release it in
fifteen hundred theaters Wow and we were
the number one movie that summer for
like four or five weeks in a row that
isn't cool right okay that's the kind of
stuff right dude back then they used to
release like four movies all right I
mean that was days Yeah right I mean I
was I mean I couldn't go anywhere it was
like I everywhere I went was like it was
like I'm ever going to the movies with
this I had a date I went to the movies
with this chick and westwood in the like
the manager came over and like took me
and goes do what would you like you know
and he like had me go sit down and
brought me popcorn and like I was like
wow so got laid that night that is so
good of course yeah oh I have two
questions for you 1 i'm gonna take a
step back for just a second because
obviously you do do stand-up comedy so
i'm curious that you weren't weren't
doing stand-up back no no no no but i'm
curious did you not only is it exciting
to be around the people that your name
like the Don Rickles of the Steve
Martin's or the George Burns but did you
actually pay attention to what they were
doing and and we did you ever find
yourself learning from them and did you
pull influences from those people as you
go along or were you just like oh cool
there's those people I'm fascinated by
them or were you actually kind of always
a
a student I was I would think I was
really was a student most of the time I
thought it was TVs just going to come on
here well you got the the NFL training
camp and you guys got a mind of its own
got another guy in a striped suit um but
no you know what I did I did learn I did
try to learn especially it was more it
was easier to kind of learn from the
younger guys that were more my age
because the older guys they just kind of
did it I mean it was really fascinated
by how fast they were what I said I mean
like Don Rickles was one of my favorite
people in the world yeah like he used to
do i I really got that by the [ __ ] I
got him good like he used to he used to
really [ __ ] with people and in a loving
way but he would do stuff I mean he knew
everybody's name and I remember going
down how do you know everybody's name
man on the crew he goes in case I get
robbed I want to know who to have
arrested you know he's to say [ __ ] like
that and then what he would always do is
is I was standing in for Rickles and it
was John Landis who was very mean he was
a very mean guy he was just getting
ready to go on trial for that yeah those
advocating twilight zone by the way you
stood in for John Stamos and Don Rickles
and and Elliott Gould I did at photo
double elegant where they they they had
to glue hair on my chest because they
did a cutaway shot where it basically I
would I was laying down on a cot and I
would and I would sit up and then he
would just appear they didn't want to
cut they wanted to literally look like
he just appeared in the doorway and and
I had and I mean they literally I had to
spend like three hours while they just
they glue this mop of [ __ ] on me because
he was so [ __ ] hairy Mia I mean that
guy was like a grizzly bear and and I
was like it was like 21 it's just no
hair on my chest and they just glue this
just looks like I just got this huge
[ __ ] all over my god you didn't take it
out that night and ladies huh um but
trickles used to always come up and he
would always go hey kid hold this he'd
hit pop my papa's scriptum actually hold
this professionals are going to work
right now there you go you let the
professionals do this you know you kept
doing that he goes any cocoa is called
me kid so one night one of the last shot
the night we had there was a penthouse
magazine on set and I was just [ __ ]
around and he was he was doing a scene
you know we're in this thing and I
started tearing out these pages of these
chicks with her legs spread it's
penthouse it's not playtime rise like
this is like you know lips it was like
disgusting and in a good way but um so I
started signing it like to Don does this
look familiar love like like Trina or
something you know I started taking
these and I just stick him in the script
pages and I just got sticking him in a
script and I just thought I he'll get a
kick out of this you know he'll get a
laugh out of this and then the next day
like seven thirty in the morning i'm
standing on set you know because we're
getting ready for the first shot and
Rickles come is worth the kid where's
the kid I got to talk to the kid and he
comes up to me he goes my wife and helps
me memorize my lines in bed at night he
goes you got me kid that was like he was
such a cool guy but he was like oh my is
one of those things where it was like
there were so many cool things you know
that got to happen on that you know and
you know that was one of like I gotta
say that was probably the best time I
ever you know even being that young you
know you're working at Universal Studios
you know you're on the back lot every
day and like we're net worth shooting
next door to amazing stories where
Steven Spielberg's doing his show you
know you're you have hopes you have
dreams your young enough that your
careers not over and the environments
all around you at all times do you
actually feel like okay this is what
Hollywood is located in the more days
we're throwing the football with Robert
Redford on the back lot like we're like
we're playing were it between sound
stages and Robert Redford was doing that
movie i think it was like legal eagles
we have Michelle Pfeiffer Daryl Hannah
Daryl Hannah when she was hot she she
listened to the show yeah yes um but get
a look of belief for just one second I
don't worry about me um but she but like
he was back there we'd be throwing the
football he like he'd walk out anybody
hit me you know and you know so you're
tossing the ball with Redford it was
just a time when you know Hollywood
wasn't nothing was corporate you know
and that's what that's what I think
really sucks not just about Hollywood
but about this whole country is that
it's become so corporate that there's
nothing really independent anymore you
know and and back then everybody was you
know Universal was its thing you know
and then there was Fox and there was you
know Warner Brothers there were these
studios and they kind of made these they
kind of made these great movies and they
did these things everybody worked you
know if you went out and you would you
audition for a show and you did a good
job you [ __ ] got the part right you
know and it was like but now it's like
well we're gonna read you but really
we've got this kid that's on a reality
show that's that does YouTube that we
really think it'd be much better than
this so we can get some YouTube hits
more Twitter followers for our [ __ ]
show yeah it's like go [ __ ] yourself
won't you [ __ ] higher quality people
you know because there's so many quality
people out there and now it just doesn't
make a [ __ ] bit of different quality
doesn't equal a safe bet not anymore
like I think the to your point is that
it used to like quality was like if you
changed when the entertainment business
has changed drastically I mean it
drastically drastically however you know
you can't give up I mean we all we all
fight the good fight and you shouldn't
give up I mean unless you're just done
with it but it's it's a it's a shock if
you're terrible at it you should give up
you'll just ever make that's probably
good no but I mean it's just it's at it
is harder now it really is hard to get
your stuff through because you know III
can't tell how many times when I'm
trying to get my movie made how they'll
talk to me about like well who's in it
and how many followers they have and
it's like I want to cut that point I
want to vomit because I'm like there's
nothing to do with this movie yeah and
that's the thing but that the one other
side of that that's I think that allowed
some things is like you can go make a
show now and you can you know if you can
give you can do it if you can find a way
to get something you know get to make
one make two and show it to Netflix or
Amazon or show it to somebody if its
quality they're gonna [ __ ] put it on
there's more plaid I mean look at its
Always Sunny in Philadelphia nobody knew
these [ __ ] guys and I know that's one
in a million deal but I know that that's
not the quality rises to the top I do
when you fire on all cylinders it does
find its way yeah and I think that you
know that's a thing where they got there
was nobody was known and then they
brought in Danny DeVito and he kind of
brought it over the top but I don't
think anybody
I don't think they had to have that to
make it happen but I think it was just a
nice you know thing they put on it but
if they didn't have eight Danny DeVito's
and one guy rhino and that's kind of
what's happening now more and more you
see that happening and it's just I mean
I was talking to somebody other day and
they go oh yeah where they got this
YouTube person it's like you what do
they do on you to all will they dude
it's like oh [ __ ] them yeah you know
just because people have nothing better
to do then follow some [ __ ] putz on
YouTube it's like they're not doing
anything no they're not doing anything
interesting there's a couple very
talented people on YouTube and I hope
that they they actually find a way to
bridge the gap but then there's all this
other stuff that I just don't understand
I don't either and the funny thing is is
is all you people are buying into these
guys in the fact of the matter is you're
buying into [ __ ] and it ends up biting
them in the ass anyway because at the
end of the day it's like nobody really
follows that [ __ ] now and you know what
an executive can say is when if they
give somebody some youtubers show and
that showed fails like well this guy had
a million followers so blame this guy
his followers doing it under the show
you're missing the point it actually
goes back to these arguments if
sometimes like why do certain actors
continue to get movies it's because even
though the movies are [ __ ] it still
makes us money back and that's the thing
is just two different ways to make you
know it's a product at the other day
absolutely so these this YouTube thing
it has been working the product is [ __ ]
but everybody that invested in it guess
what they all got their money back and
then some and they'll continue to crank
out the [ __ ] the thing is do you want to
be known as the guy yeah they're cranks
out [ __ ] or do you actually want to make
something that you want to make and take
your chances I mean that's really the
choice you have to make sure it's like
75 percent of people would take the
first I'll be the guy to crack yeah i
think i just think i think there's going
to be i think there's going to come a
time where it is you start to look at
the shows that do rise you look at shows
like orange is the new black you look at
a house of cards you look at the night i
granted this is david fincher I mean
you've got you guys NZ Basie yeah but I
know that but I mean I'm still saying
that these these forums for this you
look at the different people that are in
house of cards not everybody is a known
actor nah you look at some of these
shows there there are some opportunities
that are coming out there and and I do
like that that that that's happening I
do think that I do think that we're
going to see the end of network TV
for long it's just gonna be all game
shows and [ __ ] which it pretty much is
now for the most part news people say I
don't know about that i'm like i say to
you ladies and gentleman I present to
you MTV yeah do you see a music video on
the music television network no that's
what happy before get it just eventually
over time they phase out whatever they
when they're not they're not making that
they're not making the decisions that a
company like Netflix is making where
it's like yeah let's put this edgy show
on there like can't but then I'm looking
fired yeah and I just passing on things
that are but I can I don't come it all
comes from I think it all comes from the
one base thing is is that you don't have
creative people in those positions and
make decisions anymore they're all
people that were in law school that rose
through some kind of ranks there's no
creativity in there I mean you got to
give les Moonves credit I mean that guy
for whatever reason he puts I mean he at
least has as had a creative mind he when
he least has made some creative
decisions and I think you start looking
at like there are creative people out
there they just they're not in the right
position to do these things then you
look at who runs you know who runs some
of these net with the the netflix and
that you know HBO and some of these
things these people are into the
creative [ __ ] and so that's why
everybody is watching show time
everybody is watching HBO because
they're it's not that the language is
that or the material is that edgy it's
just that there's great [ __ ] man
subscriber base is how is where the
safety net comes in the fact that they
don't have to report to and yes they
don't have a report to somebody who gets
angry because they did were offended by
something and they call McDonald's until
McDonald's to stop advertising on there
which shuts down a show HBO showtime
Netflix Amazon they don't worry about it
that stuff let's see I think that's I
think that's a crock of [ __ ] too because
I think anytime McDonald's pulls out
burger king will come in and I think
anytime that there's things that they're
they say there's no threatened by it's
just a way to Center it's just the right
and I hate to say this but it's just
that kind of scared right wing [ __ ]
that's still it's still out there you
know they call Hollywood real left left
you know we're all we're all the way to
the left and we should because otherwise
you wouldn't get creative stuff
otherwise you just be catering to a very
specific audience you should be catering
to everything and so happens but I think
you do I think you still have a little
that to the right you know the safety
the Christian let's put that with a
christian coalition of stuff that still
is still kind of like trying to censor
stuff down and it's called turn off the
television yeah it's change it well
we'll put it on after nine o'clock I
mean you know whatever yeah but just
turn off the TV yeah change a channel if
you're worried about what your kids
watch I have a couple of them you know
how you handle it don't worry don't
watch it yeah i mean it's it's so funny
i mean i remember i was talking to
somebody the other night we were talking
about was saturday night live because i
remember when i was a kid watching
Saturday Night Live the original with
the original cast I think Oh was it
really that funny and I go I don't know
that it was necessarily as funny as
eddie murphy and Billy Crystal and that
kind of comedy comedy stuff but it was
so [ __ ] edgy yes I'm and it was [ __ ]
they were doing [ __ ] no body was doing
it was if it was a fascination to watch
what was going oh my god I mean yes they
were coked out of their minds and doing
the same stuff but they were still like
they were still amazing like it was
still like how cutting-edge was it there
was nothing even remotely close to that
at the time because you only had three
networks you know you're gonna have for
Network she had three and after at that
point nothing was on like when Senate
life was on at that time at night there
was another channel had anything on it
oh no yummy watching that you're not
watching TV yeah you're a teenager you
get to stay up late on Saturday night
and you get to watch Saturday Night Live
you watch blue she is the samurai and
you watch you know father Guido Sarducci
just knew had weed yeah yeah and it was
just like that was the coolest [ __ ]
thing ever at the time but we don't I
don't think we have that anymore I don't
think there's I don't think we've I
think there's so much of the Internet
has ruined all that so there's not going
to really be other than maybe two clowns
[ __ ] on a high wire yanira during
pay-per-view you know trying to get
pregnant and have triplets I mean how
you know where do you go I'll Mike Tyson
and Ronda Rousey beat each other sounds
exactly well this is a little bit of a
transition I mean this was the argument
when I because I want to get into doing
that when you chose to do stand-up and
and the thing is as we all know in this
room we can't pretend like we don't know
this but what the improv was in the 90s
is not what the improv is now and
everybody talked about when it went
corporate
where you could no longer just walk into
a room and you know the guy that was
working the door you know and work in
the room you could she could you could
work that guy and you can get on stage
and all that stuff it became a corporate
entity and sort of branching out and
becoming you know McDonald's if you will
or starbucks were started opening up in
other cities and it changed and they
said that that kind of changed the face
of stand up when stand up became
corporate as well I mean so it's like
you see it everywhere like what you're
talking about it everything just kind of
becomes this corporate get a little bit
safer a little bit only book these
comedians to do this stuff to entertain
to this audience the same community
taking chances it's the same comedians
every every night it's the same
committee fuka if you go out on
Hollywood for the most part for the most
part you got krystalya krystalya
krystalya you know because he's the hot
and I love crystally it's not I'm not I
thought has nothing to do with this is
the comedian you take any gig they give
yeah it has nothing to do with him it's
like you know you've got you know you've
got this guy at you know you know Maz
Jobrani is always at the Laugh Factory
you've got you know it's just it's the
the same guys it's just it in and I
don't understand how it's weird to me
it's like in The Comedy Store you never
used to be like that and now the comedy
store is like that yeah the comedy
stores you know there's still there
still is that Clubhouse to it I mean you
know I gotta give Adam Adam egan credit
for you know taking over a position that
was basically run by a racist you know
[ __ ] insane dude yeah you know and it
was it's one way of putting it yeah I
mean that's not my older way but yeah
that's the nice way to put it but you
know at the same time though you know he
was trying even in his own disgusting
mind was trying to follow Mitzi's what
mitts he wanted you know that was that
it didn't matter how big you were you
were still that that place was a gym
where you worked out and I don't think
any other room was like that at the time
you know it's that the getting again
there was nobody there in the gym right
so you know you could work out all you
wanted there was nobody in the audience
not like a gym yeah but now I mean now
it's packed again it's I mean it's
definitely the hottest club in town by
far and I mean and you've got people
coming in that didn't use to come in
and but I agree with you I think there's
just something about stand up you know
cuz I met you when I first started I
remember I cuz I I was it was like 2,000
I got sober what you know to be honest
with you I I had a little bit of a
problem for a for a very long time and
and then I cleaned up my act and I
always wanted to do stand-up from the
time I was in college I'd always wanted
to do stand-up and and then someone told
me about Adam Barnard and I always
didn't know like in to this day if
anybody says how did is the good
stand-up teacher and it's like nobody
really can teach stand up no but Adam
Barnhart is the best [ __ ] guy to get
you at least started in the right
direction I think he cuz he doesn't try
to teach you a quote on quote technique
he just tries to teach you how to get
out of the way of yourself and be
yourself and I thought that was really
cool and then you know and then you
would go to his class and I did his
class and then you'd showcased at The
Comedy Store and of course it was all
dick and tit jokes you know what yeah at
the time you talk about what you know
he'll probably he clearly knows about
that what about the dick stuff you know
like a lot of us use it yeah you were
yeah but that's I mean any is so funny
because like I just I think about the
first things I talked about it was like
it was so bad but you wanted time to way
to being at war a few if that's the
thing about comedy is like it's an
evolution right if you so choose for it
to be in your first job when you when
you do stand-up it's just figure out how
to make somebody laugh on this weird
stage that you're standing exactly
that's it we should never judge
ourselves too harshly on the material we
started well you were always a guy I
really looked up to because i always
remember when i was going in there and
then i got to be on the sunday night
regulars so it's like you would you
basically i was the one who would put
the candles on the table to get like
four minutes you know i mean it's like
on sunday nights and there was me and
Lisa Joffrey and Melanie vesi but there
was you and Brian Keith Etheridge were
like the [ __ ] dudes man they were the
guys that came in and had like 20
minutes of [ __ ] you know rock and
material and I always looked up to you
always thought you I was thought like
what a great comic and and I always
admired you because you I really i
thought you were you know what still do
but I mean I'm saying but especially at
that time I was like holy [ __ ] this
guy's
really that's like way I want to be able
to be and and it was great at that time
too because the comedy store wasn't that
busy it wasn't that crazy wild west it
was the Wild West and you know I I was
getting you know you got in the comedy
store if you were sunday night we did
adam sunday night room and you get in so
you got to do i was there every Sunday
night for almost three years you know
and i think you know two years in you
know i think i finally got to showcase
for Mitzi you know didn't get even close
to even her even like even looking up
from her popcorn you know here's the
thing about the showcase if you're a
showcase their I have so you always hear
the [ __ ] I for me waiting do you
remember the first you remember the
first time you showcase oh god you so
they all tell you that you better watch
out because comics try to get in her ear
and get a distractor from watching the
comedian's either was like this whole
thing [ __ ] you get this whole thing they
tell you before you go on stage but the
but what you realize after you go
through it is in the end it doesn't
[ __ ] matter i mean you could crush it
and not become a regular and you
couldn't eat ass and be get to call the
next day congratulations you're in you
just really didn't know as long as the
key was though and there was some truth
in the fact if she didn't want you you
were [ __ ] yeah she didn't want you
were [ __ ] but the cool thing was too
is it's like-- you uh it back then Mitzi
would come in every Sunday and every
Monday night no matter what she was
sitting the back in that chair have
glass of wine and popcorn and she would
have a showcase list her list of
showcases and Duncan Trussell was like
the Booker you know he was like not the
Booker but he was the rid of the talent
guy oh yeah he was more or less to tell
guy he didn't want weird to think of
that now I forget he's a dozen when i
first started like kind of poking my
head in there yeah he was not he was
always fared i always the greatest guy
man that the sweetest guy in the world
and Duncan used to Duncan would help me
out and he would go he tried to get me
in every six months or so number right
second time nothing you know and then
the third time I finally went up for
Luca palanka remember Luca yes Luca is
now married to tammy pescatelli [ __ ]
sweetheart I knew Luca forever and Luca
goes don't worry I got your back so he's
like making sure nobody got her [ __ ]
here
and and I remember seeing him pushing
and I won't say what comic it was you
bastard pushing the comic away because
no comic want you to get past right you
know what real estate names time for
this any time for them and so and the
thing was is I knew I wasn't ready to
like I mean I was still I still very new
I don't even do a comedy about two years
maybe two and a half years but I had
done so much theatre and done so much
stuff I was very comfortable on stage
yeah like I didn't have any problem in
part kind of had that stuff done I just
didn't have the material like it wasn't
like ironed out but so I went up and I
did fairly clean stuff for her talked
about my family and stuff and I remember
walking off stage and she looked up she
goes you want to get some spats and and
I'm telling you this is like if you're a
comedian and Mitzi shore passes you like
Don Corleone is it's just like Don
Corleone going you know like just like
[ __ ] tapping you on the head you walk
it you walk down through the you walk
down the three steps and then you're
high-fiving your [ __ ] way through the
hallway just [ __ ] you're just it's
like you just won the Super Bowl or just
you're holding the Stanley Cup yeah I
remember I got past and then I called in
and I got I got a spot at nine o'clock
on like wednesday night to open the show
I didn't get a spot for six months after
that that's what she would do what
sounds about right yeah because what you
do is you could work out on Sunday
Monday now you were paid regular so she
would want to see if you wanted it if
you were going to work on it because she
told me afterwards later that night she
said she goes you're not ready but at
least now you have a place to work out
and you have a stage to work out on you
need to work on your material and so she
wanted to see if you wanted it so when
you go in on sundays and mondays now and
need the potluck would the Poliquin and
all the other stuff would be all the the
new stuff and the employees was over at
nine-thirty ok so the lights went off
the 930 that was it 930 that was done
and then there was show cases til ten
o'clock if there were showcases but
Mitzi was there at nine thirty she would
catch the tail into the employees and
most employees we didn't want to go up
at that point because Mitzi was there
none of the paid regular size
so funny they were scared to go run they
would shat they would scatter because
she would leave about 10-15 so she would
be in there so that I mean literally
Tommy who is not the Booker but he was
working the cover booth he was basically
this when he first started stealing so
Tommy would be at the front and Tommy
would like go out and he would look for
somebody to do a spot in the paid
regulars would as soon as they saw Tommy
they would go to the front well sure
they were afraid that she was gonna hate
them all of a sudden and unpaid record
unpinned and get ever kicked out yeah
get banned everything wrong yeah and
it's crazy but if you were new you could
go [ __ ] I'll go up because you had
nothing to lose right and she might hate
you that night she usually did she never
liked you she never she would never go
good job ever Wow never would she say
that a jar is very high for the people
that started there so it's kinda always
know that but you could go up every
Sunday and Monday you can go up and do
10 minutes every Sunday and Monday and
you're like holy [ __ ] you know and then
back then there were so many rooms
around to you could go do spots at
westwood you could do do all these other
things ruko yeah so it was always it was
always fun but that was one of the great
getting passed by her was a huge deal so
you had been working at you moved out
her in 84 when did you actually first
take the stage and stand up when you
said [ __ ] it I'm gonna do stand-up 2002
2002 so almost twenty years in your like
finally thinking to yourself alright I
gotta do this and what was the bug that
after 20 years you finally decided i
don't know i just well you said it was
you got you got clean well i mean is
that it was that or it has nothing to do
with it was it yeah a little bit it was
like I cuz I was always I mean I was a
mess from like 92 92 to two thousand one
was pretty those are the dark days the
court mikkel it was dark it was it was
not it was not a pretty it was not
pretty i moved to new york for a year
you know you only have two years and and
I just you know it's just like were you
working a lot in that time no no no you
think that had a lot to do with it lot
no no finally I'd have been if I would
have if I would have worked more I
probably be dead cuz yeah well I had I
was okay on money and I wasn't that
wasn't money wasn't issue they'd all
kinds of weird jobs you know but at the
same time though if I'd had more money I
would have probably been dead
but I was good that I didn't have enough
uh yeah I always say that about my 20s
and moving out here like if I would have
gotten famous right away or gotten bunch
of money right away I'd be talking to
dead guys easily yeah the weirdest show
Oddcast ate the weird thing was is I was
never one of those guys that got work
and was like oh I'm cool like I always
kind of thought it was like such a
privilege to get the jobs and get work I
was never a dick I i I'd knock on what I
hope I was never a dino and I can attest
that because ever since the day that
I've met you've been nothing you always
does a smile on your face you're not the
guy that I ever pegged to be the angry
douchebag you're always very very very
pleasant to meet and talk to and you
handled yourself that way with everybody
and I can say that because I always such
a rakul cause you roll up on a [ __ ]
motorcycle and I always thought that was
[ __ ] cool that's because of gas
prices that's what I do that I am I my
other car is a big clunker you know an
old I have an old fat Mercedes you know
because they're cheap and they run
forever yeah they're on forever but they
just suck ass so I'm yeah I ride my
motorcycle as much as I possibly can you
know so first his first time on stage
where was it and do you remember um
first just like what the feeling was
first time in the comedy store in the
desert so the first time you ever one up
Isabella room in the colonies are a room
at the comedy store and I think nervous
I mean I definitely was nervous I mean I
don't think I was afraid you know wasn't
that it was like I think I was nervous
because I was so used to doing theater I
had done theater so many i dint so much
theater and i really like theaters like
you kind of memorize somebody else's
stuff and so there's like the emotions
kind of written in or you'd create the
emotion that's you know through that
thing but i think was stand up it's like
I didn't want to audit you know I was
learning from Adam at the time and it
was like and you don't really nothing's
planned it's like you know you know what
your jokes are you know what your stuff
is but you're not going to it's not
going to be it's gonna be this way you
know where the first thing you said when
you got sage the first joke um I don't
do you bever forgot to laugh I think I
did okay you did okay I did okay look I
always said that the first time you go
up on stage is not the is not the time
that you usually say I belong here
choose you the second or third time you
go up because then you kind of start to
see who you really are whether
want to be up there or not but what was
it for you when did you find the after
doing it the first time a couple times
when did you go you know what I'm gonna
because again you have to keep doing
stand-up this is not a once in awhile
thing I commitment yeah eyes real i
think it was it took me a while it took
me a while sure i wasn't it wasn't not
being sure it's just that I had done I
had done so much stuff in like like I
had done plays in theater where we would
run for six months you know and I would
work with these guys are amazing time
you know stuff in co so I kind of like
at a bar set really high like I need to
have you know from per meter like say
this is I'm good at this probably took a
few years you know to be honest with you
I mean I had good sets in there I had
some really no never never forget I was
with this I had been doing stand-up
about a year maybe not even a year and I
was going to a superbowl party I was
going to the Super Bowl and with the
owner of the Indianapolis Colts of
course and so we were make sense we play
golf together we are good friends and so
Jimmy or say yeah so so so we're going
down we're going down to San Diego and
we're staying at this like this this
little this resort whatever and before
we gun down he goes he goes I've hired
this guy to do stand up and I go he's
like cool ego so you're doing stand-up
now I go yeah yeah and he goes because
well why don't you why don't you open
for him and I was like I was thinking
super bowl party this is like this could
be my crowd like drunk you know drinkers
you know this would be [ __ ] awesome
yeah I'm already getting anxiety yeah
yeah and so and so Edward is recalling
their as I'm going oh this is great man
this is so fun when we get there were
down there and and I guess is about an
hour or hour and a half before the
dinner that night and he goes he goes
are you ready and I go yeah and he goes
he goes alright man he goes the kids are
gonna love this and I go excuse me and
he had Sinbad was the the oh my god he'd
hired Sinbad as the comedian and he's
done this for years he hires comedians
for they but it's the indianapolis colts
superbowl party so I mean they're not in
that they're not in the Super Bowl but
they always put all the families Peyton
Manning it's
like I mean his wife and his kids it's a
family it's not a family everybody
really in a lot of kids and a lot of
ages and I and I was like dude have you
seen my act it's all tit and dick jokes
and it's like he also he can't do though
it was like [ __ ] I go I gotta give me
one minute of material I go I'm not
gonna go i'm not gonna do it he goes oh
[ __ ] yes you are i put your [ __ ] name
on the thing you're going up and i had
this table like it was aight aight a
biggest full of [ __ ] like I add so much
[ __ ] I mean just sprang except for like
my friends that were sitting at the
table we're laughing at you and not when
you at me watching me eat [ __ ] the
entire [ __ ] time and I mean I sweated
my ass off and what are the years they
have to say when you got out state
laughed his ass he knew you all
uncomfortable you were I think he was
just like he's such a sweet guy he was
just like good try buddy buddy good try
though that's oh yeah I mean in the [ __ ]
I mean it was terrible but luckily I
mean luckily I mean you cut to 13 12
years later 12 years later and I just
had I was headlining crackers in
Indianapolis nice and him and him and
his girl came out and watched it and I
[ __ ] destroyed that room temp shin
baby it was Redemption and he was like
oh because that's all you remembered of
course no matter how much you can put
online and tell him that you've done
he's gonna remember that time you made
your own dick in front of ya children's
party is a lie dick and jacked off in
excelsis yeah every was like way too
many dicks being jacked off any all it
was so bad but the seat but to have him
come and see that show where it was like
I mean it was like one of the you know
and solid you walked away going oh yeah
it's all 50 minutes like thank you you
know yeah and it was good so it was good
to have that Redemption but it did take
about 12 years do you classify that as
your worst gig I mean for personal I
mean we all have crappy gigs but like
personally for you were you just like oh
my god not that one that sticks in your
memory that was the biggest bolas [ __ ] I
ever ate I think the worst gig I ever
did was me and this guy Paul Hughes Paul
Hughes and I were
got asked to do sunset junction music
festival oh and we thought there thought
we were going to go up and do stand-up
before like the two of us we chose go up
and do like 10 minutes and we get there
and they go no we want you guys to do
like a little buddy buddy like you know
to you know kind of like the Sklar
brothers or you know whatever I anybody
yeah never have you done you never guys
one shirt to wear yeah exactly and they
go right arm and we have to split the
check I don't know what the [ __ ] it was
and it was like soap and we and we were
opening for Phoebe Snow who's like this
old the old lesbian you know who sing
you know she's like poetry man is her
favorite favorite song or famous song
it's or in front of like these butch
dykes yeah you know it out in words
overlay outdoors at dusk and they're
just screaming take you sure tough take
you sure about kitchen you know and so
what I did was I just finally got I
taught my buddy Paul into going down and
taking a picture and they just ripped
him apart like they just like basically
did and I just made fun of them I mean I
was the worst kick that is that by far
the worst gig yes good and literally
they hated us like they hate it but what
a weird like who's booking that someone
who has no idea oh my yes they're really
you think there's no people that book
comedy and have no idea what they're
doing yeah that happens only sane like
all these people definitely love a stand
up like I did I did a gig once you
always get asked to do these parties
sometimes like I did a corporate thing
and I got i did a corporate thing for a
golf course and i just did my stand-up
and they loved it they like they were
they were really cool like they were
really took a minute but they were
really cool and then and then they the
same guy that book down asked me to do a
thing for the USC football team they
were good they're getting ready playing
the Rose Bowl and so they would have
liked this dinner as mandatory by the
way they had to be at this dinner at the
hotel and so there they show up in
sweatpants and everything and there's
like music and it's kind of a you know
whatever kind of fiesta thing going on
and they're like and then also like oh
and yeah we got a comedian for you here
and they just hand
yes i love the here's here's our intro
here yeah and all they really all the
guys mark sanchez was there Pete Carroll
it was like is back then well and all
they really want you to do is make fun
of yes yeah they just want you to make
fun of these guys and then when you do
make fun of them then they its young
guys and their feelings get hurt and so
and these are big [ __ ] guys did
football players ball players so I
started [ __ ] with this I like this
one guy started you know kind of
heckling me a little bit and I was like
and I really [ __ ] win at him and and
then he got like pissed man but I you
know cuz he kind of said some stuff and
I and he started on my family and then I
really went it is family ah I guess he
had some problems with his family well
that's weird and in and Mark Sanchez
basically had to stop it you know and so
he goes no no make fun of me make fun of
me and I was like oh the Mexican you
know and and it was like in at the end
Pete Carroll comes over to me and he
goes what a great job duty cuz I don't
know how you made it through that you
know he was like he's a nice guy wow
yeah wow you survived yeah that's some
of the stories that always happen we
will run a little short on time so i
actually just want to talk about yuvan
you've been cranking out the comedy for
years and you actually do you put out a
we what do we call now see that's what I
was just gonna say they say all things
digital distribution I like the cut I
think album is map to my gallery what
would you call it I I call it an album I
don't know eventually it'll be pressed
onto some vinyl he was gonna do it even
if somebody just spits on a piece of
vinyl I don't know but no yeah I mean
it's an album it's what I did was is I
went down I had recorded this recorded
my hour is this i recorded an hour three
times before and I done it for eight
years in I did earn seven years in I did
it like nine years in and whatever you
know I kind of but it was never right
like I didn't like I wouldn't listen to
it so I'm like [ __ ] I'm not gonna
because I see a lot of guys put out an
album and it's like really that's what
you're going to put out there that's
what you cuz everyone's gonna listen to
this and it doesn't go away there's your
benchmark you know so it's like I mean
yeah there's the shitty YouTube set you
have a ther but so what you know but so
finally I just I went down to la jolla
comedy store which is one of my favorite
places in the world and I did I did this
hour over four nights and i really only
used one show ok so it's and I I got
this great recording engineer it sounds
freaking amazing even if you hate the
jokes the sound mixing mixing it a
[ __ ] top shelf I hear someone went on
the grooming yeah what we did is we
actually took the mics and we put the
mics behind the stage the audience mics
so you actually hear what I hear what
it's like to be on stage oh wow any show
all right so you actually get to hear
what it's like to [ __ ] murder kidding
no but I had such a great time doing it
and it was it was the stuff that I was
done doing it's all the material I was
done with yeah you know and and I think
that's what it should be I think that's
why I yeah it is ed and I think it and I
think it's the material that evolved
into what it evolved in I'm you know
they're like you know two years ago I do
a bit about going on a cruise ship it
was it was four minutes now it's eight
minutes here you know it's like just all
the things that I finally like okay
that's as far as I can go with that
subject and and I just I like it I like
the album I think it's good i think it's
funny I've listened to it and actually
gone yeah that's that that's that's a
well that was a well-crafted joke know
that I spent you know after three hours
without Madrigal at a coffee shop you
know we figured that one out you know
and and that's what we used to do I mean
you know as comics you know that you sit
down with guys and it's still your
material but you're you it's always good
to like bounce it off people and that
stuff had been you know eight years in
the making and most of the stuff is
probably three years three years old you
know I mean or two or three years old
but I mean I like the album I really do
I like the album and and I hope you know
hope you're listening to it it's it's
it's fun to put that out and go yeah I'm
proud of this let's go it's called live
from Pearl Street yeah which is where
the la jolla comedy store is located its
own pearl street so and i thought it was
so funny i was talking to Tom papa one
night and I had some III have a joke
that I do that I talked about and I
don't mind I can do the joke here it's
no big deal it's like it'll rain the
album it's only 30 second joke but I
talked about like Instagram you know
nice and at the end of the thing I say
you know you'll never see the dalai lama
post a selfie with this back arched his
ball sack hanging out hashtag blessed
you know and i saw i was going to call
the album hashtag blessed and and I was
telling Tom pop of this and then he goes
now that's just that's that's not good
that's not this it's something some
Christian album and I was like yo what
do you make all alive from Pearl Street
and he goes ooh that's a great name and
so I just kind of was like thanks Tom
papa you know I'm out um I just I love
it I did a good friend in Vegas did the
artwork for me and you know I this guy
Mike Duncan did the sounding sound
engineer he's great he's [ __ ]
phenomenal sounds great get the goddamn
get a goddamn out go download it's only
999 I mean you spend that on coffee
these days yeah right exactly johnd and
more than that I spend thirty dollars a
taco bell for gas they fancy this would
be a good thing you put your put your
headphones on do around the golf listen
to a live from Pearl Street yeah it's
this is it this is a good ride home this
is a good Rhino man I had somebody that
was really funny like you know you get
every now and then you get these twitter
messages for somebody and they somebody
download of the album and the guy goes
you just told me about my you just
basically transcribed my first and
second marriage and I was like okay good
get it out were you ever married no no
no look at him yeah yeah right you're
like you're still kept together good
look in you got tan you're like smile
you got them happy it's got damn Steve
McQueen over there yeah I got a buddy in
there yeah I want you though I I it's
gonna happen yeah just not for a while
no there's nothing wrong with that you
know I again I can't stress enough i
have not doing this because my wife
doesn't listen so i'm not trying to do
anything to get out of anything but i
got a good i made the right choices you
know I vib a schlub I mean you you
always struck me as a very very happy
person like a very even-keeled person
you don't walk up you know Oh what no no
I'm joined by John may be passing look
Brian so happy but deeper conversation
reveals whatever man now let's show no
you're a happy guy I mean you're not
you're when you're when you're when you
get mad you're not mad at your situation
in life or where you are in life or mad
at you or you're probably mad at
something I did yeah but I think that's
like I mean you you know over the years
we've still a movie see
each other and it's like yeah you're not
somebody who walks up going like where's
my where's my [ __ ] where's my [ __ ] and a
nuts and that's kind of hard to be
around it's hard for me you know and I
kind of catch myself to catch myself and
go you're where you're supposed to be
just shut the [ __ ] up and enjoy your
life I don't you know I'm not young
anymore so well did you don't look old
I'll tell you that you look you look
very in shape maybe it's the golfing
maybe it's you will not marry you yeah
maybe you're not very merry no he's not
going to marry you please marry me I
think it's the eight I don't know it
says you're real skinny yeah core thank
you so much lucky grocery allied enjoy
pick it up and your twitter is at court
mccowan cor TMCC oh w and just like the
football player and you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna continue to be out
and about gigs right i met i know i'm at
the comedy store this weekend sometime I
you know have you gone the new ha great
[ __ ] club yeah it is actually it's a
nice room thank you changin I hope that
comedy has a bull man I feel like it's
common and I feel like actually social
media as much as we r AG down an earlier
i think is good for comedy I think this
digital media is good for comedy I think
YouTube is good for stand-up comedy I
think we're going to see a lot of great
stand-up comedy come on our way it's
kind of we talked about earlier when
it's good it shows up somewhere people
find the good they really do absolutely
look at Sebastian Maniscalco was the
funniest he's all [ __ ] funny to never
never done a TV show never done never
been on any you know never had any of
that stuff and when it sells out
theaters now so he died to another
[ __ ] great guy I actually have never
met him personally or talk to him
because he Tim it's the hell out of me
for some reason but he is I I keep
watching we should be embarrassed every
time it comes on showtime I just watch
it it's it his Chicago he is like a guy
I went to high school with who just
makes me laugh because he's [ __ ]
points out everyone being douchebags
it's it's pretty fantastic yeah I find
him hilarious all right court thank you
so much thank you guys thank you so much
for having me guys all right
thank you for listening to Hollywood
anonymous don't forget to follow us on
twitter at hollywood a nanny that is
short for hollywood anonymous you can
also follow john individually at John
Huck and myself Brian or when at Brian
or went on Twitter as well both of us
can be found on facebook you can also
google us and contact us directly
Hollywood anonymous guys at gmail.com
thank you again so much for listening
and please don't forget to subscribe